Transcriber: Kirollos Rizk
المدقّق: Muhammad Ramadan
مرحبًا جميعا كيف حالكم اليوم
محادثتي اليوم عنوانه
فيلم ثلاثي الأبعاد مجاني
( الموهبة قادرة دائما علي الفعل)
العنوان مربك ومن الصعب تصديقه
لكنه ليس مستحيل وسنرى لماذا
في البداية، اسمحوا أن أقدم نفسي
اسمي كيرلس رزق
عمري 21 عامًا، في الواقع
سيصبح عمري 21 في يونيو
أعمل مخرج الأفلام ثلاثية الأبعاد
ومؤلف روايات منذ عام 2010
إلى جانب كوني محاضرًا
في المجال نفسه في أماكن عدة
دعونا نبدأ هذه المحادثة بقصة قصيرة
في يوم من الأيام
في يومٍ من الأيام كنت أشاهد هاري بوتر
على التلفاز وأنا احتسي الشاي
أثناء الفلم تبادرت إلى ذهني فكرة جنونية
فسألت نفسي لم لا اصنع فيلمًا كهذا
لماذا هذا مستحيل؟
ظللت صامتًا للحظات ثم احتسيت بعض الشاي
ثم تساءلت عن سبب تسمية مدرسة السحر
هوغوورتس بهذا الاسم
لم لا يُطلَق عليها اسم
ثانوية السحر للبنين؟
[ضحك الجمهور]
لم البطل اسمه هاري؟
لم ليس اسمه عباس او محسن؟
أين الجديد في الموضوع،
أين الصعب، أين المستحيل؟
بدأت أفكر أكثر فأكثر حتى تملكتني الفكرة
حتى لم يبق أمامي إلا خيارين
أما أن أترك كوب الشاي والفيلم
واعمل على تحقيق فكرتي الجنونية
أو أكمل الفيلم والشاي وأنسى الفكرة
لو كنتم مكاني، ماذا ستفعلون
لنصوت
من منكم كان سيترك كوب الشاي
ليعمل علي الفكرة فليرفع يده
[ضحك الجمهور]
شيء مبشر للغاية
من منكم كان سيترك الفكرة
ويكمل الفيلم
[ضحك الجمهور]
قلب كبير
في الحقيقة لقد تركت كوب الشاي
وتركت الفيلم
بدأت ابحث عن خطوتي القادمة
فأحضرت ورقة و قلم و جلست و بدأت
في كتابة كل ما حضر بذهني
خطوة فخطوة بدأت في كتابة جزء فجزء
اضيف التفاصيل وانتقل من مشهد لأخر
الفكرة البسيطة التي ظهرت من كوب شاي
أثناء فيلم هاري بوتر
تحولت لرواية من 5 فصول خلال ثلاث أشهر
بعد ثلاث أشهر وجدت معي رواية
ولكني لم اتخذ أي خطوات
إيجابية لعمل فيلما بعد
فبدأت في البحث عن خطوتي القادمة
فبحثت في شبكة الإنترنت عن الخطوات
التقليدية لعمل أي فيلم
وبالفعل بدأت في البحث
حتي وجدت خطوات كثيرة وهذه هي أهم النقاط
هم عشر خطوات
فبدأت بمراجعة ما تم انجازه منهم
لمعرفة ما تم انجازة والخطوات المتبقية
وجدت اني انهيت الفكرة
وخسرت خلالها كوب الشاي
وانهيت مرحلة تطوير الفكرة والتي تركت
فيها الفيلم للعمل علي الفكرة
أما الأسكريبت فقد وجدت معي رواية كاملة
وليس اسكريبت فقط
وجدت نفسي قد نجحت في انجاز ثلاث خطوات
من أصل عشرة خطوات
فتحمثت وظننت أنه بأمكاني انهاء خطوتان
أو ثلاثة بننفس اليوم سريعا
ولكني وجدت أن مرحلة ما قبل الأنتاج هي
المرحلة التي عادة ما تقف عندها
المشاريع المستقلة
ماذا تعني مشاريع مستقلة؟
هي المشاريع أو الأفلام التي يقوم
بها أفراد و ليس مؤسسات أو شركات انتاج
فوقفت مفكرًا...
هل ضاع مجهودي خلال ثلاثة أشهر
كلا أنا لست مقتنعا بهذا
ما هو الشيء الذي يوقف هذه المشاريع دائما؟
فبدأت في البحث عن ما أحتاجه لتخطي
هذه المرحلة الصعبة
فوجدت العديد من المتطلبات وأهمها ثلاث
رأس مال كبير جدا
فريق عمل ضخم جدا
واستوديو
في الواقع أنا لم أملك أي من هذا وكنت
في ثانوية عامة حينها
ففكرت ايقف المشروع عند هذه النقطة؟
يا للخسارة علي كوب الشاي
الذي ضاع في البداية
فبدأت في التفكير في احتمالية نجاحي في عمل
مشروع أو فيلم في هذه الظروف الضعيفة
إذا كنتم مكاني... سأسألكم هذا السؤال
أتظنون أن هناك فيلما قد يتم صناعته بدون
رأس مال أو فريق أو استوديو بالمجان؟
من يظن أن ذلك ممكنا فليرفع يده
أنتم متفائلون
في الحقيقة الفيلم لم يتوقف وها هو
الملصق الدعائي للفيلم
لقد قمنا بعمل هذا الملصق خصيصا
لمؤتمر اليوم
الملصق الرسمي والفيديو الدعائي
سيصدرون أخر الشهر
كيف؟ دائما ما اسأل نفسي هذا السؤال
حينما أفكر
الحقيقة لقد فكرنا في عمل حملة
لقد جلست لأفكر في كوني بحاجة لفريق
إذا سوف أبحث عن قائمة التخصصات التي
احتاجها لعمل فريق للفيلم الخاص بي
وعلي هذا الأساس بدأت في البحث عن مجموعات
موقع فيسبوك في هذه المجالات
وبدأت في الأنضمام لهذه المجموعات
خلال فترة قصيرة أصبحت عضوا
في عددا كبيرا من التجمعات
وجدت نفسي في مجموعات خاصة بممثلين
مغنيين، فنانين، كتاب، مخرجين
وصناع أفلام من جميع أنحاء العالم
ومن جنسيات مختلفة لتصبح صفحتي علي
موقع فيسبوك و كأنها أستوديو كبير جدا
أصبح لدي مدخل لكل هذه المجالات
ولكن كيف لي أن اقنعهم بالانضمام لي؟
كيف أقنعهم
فبدأت في التفكير فشيء يغريهم
للانضمام لفريقي
فعملت حملة اسمها
(الموهبة قادرة دائما علي الفعل)
لتصبح هذه الحملة كالمفتاح السحري لجذب
كل هؤلاء الناس للانضمام لفريقي
لنحل أكبر مشكلتين لدينا وهم
رأس المال والفريق
يوم 1 يوليو عام 2014 كنت قد أنتهيت من
التجهيز للحملة وقررت أن أبدأ في التنفيذ
وبالفعل في هذا التاريخ طرحت هذه الحملة
في كل مكان في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وفي هذه اللحظة بدأ السحر
"تبدأ الموسيقي"
في الحقيقة لقد كنت متأكدا منذ اليوم الأول
للحملة أنها ستحقق نجاحا
ولكني لم أتوقع هذا الحجم من النجاح
مئات الناس قدمت يوميا للدخول في الفريق
قدم الألاف خلال فترة الحملة كاملة
إن لم يكونوا مئات الألاف
كنت أقوم بعمل 60 مقابلة شخصية في اليوم
كان المتقدمين من جنسيات مختلفة
من جميع انحاء العالم
من جميع فئات الشعب
ومن جميع الطبقات الاجتماعية
من ألمانيا، إيرلندا، الصين، الهند، أوغندا
غانا، مصر، أستراليا، أمريكا
من جميع أنحاء العالم
لم نترك مكانا لم نصل إليه
حتي الدول الحديثة
كان لدينا شخص ممثل من كل دولة في العالم
ما الذي أقنع كل هؤلاء للدخول في الفريق؟
كان العرض في الحملة كالتالي
كنا نبحث عن الموهوبين غير القادرين
علي إظهار موهبتهم للعالم
الموهوبين الباحثين عن فرصة
ليظهروا موهبتهم لمن حولهم
لقد كنا هذه الفرصة
كان الاتفاق أننا سنوفر لك فرصة العمل بفيلم
مجانا بدون أي التزامات أو عقد أو مال
سوف تعطينا موهبتك وسنعطيك الفرصة لتظهرها
يبدو الاتفاق بسيطا
ولكن هذا الاتفاق البسيط قد نجح في جمع
عدد لا متناهي من الأفراد
لقد كنا منتشرين علي مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
منذ 1 يوليو 2014 وحتي
1 يوليو 2015
خلال سنة من المقابلات الشخصية لأفراد
من جميع أنحاء العالم
1 يوليو 2015 وهو أخر يوم للحملة
وأول يوم عمل
كان أصبح فريقي 120 فردا من 12 جنسية
وتعرض صورهم حاليا
ولكن الأمر لم يكن بهذا الكمال
منذ أول يوم عمل و بدأت المشكلات
كانت أنواع المشكلات كثيرة
كنا نتوقع بعض منها،
كرأس المال والاستوديو
ولكن كانت هناك مشكلات أخري غير متوقعة
فقد حللنا مشكلة رأس المال والأستوديو
بالحملة والعمل علي شبكة الأنترنت ببساطة
سوف نتعامل علي شبكة الأنترنت
سوف نقوم بعمل مجموعة علي موقع فيسبوك
ونعمل جميعا من خلالها
ولكن ظهرت مشكلة كبيرة
كيف سنعالج فرق التوقيت بيننا
نحن موجودون في جميع قارات العالم
تحديد معاد مقابلة موحدةفي نفس الوقت
ويناسب الجميع هو أمر مستحيل بنسبة 100%
فبدأت تغيير نظام نومي
سوف أسهر طوال الليل
وأظل مستيقظا بالنهار وانام
ظهرا وحتي بداية الليل
لأتمكن من مواكبة كل فروق التوقيت
ولكن الموضوع لم يكتمل
لأن شركات الأنترنت دخلت بطريقة
(نهارك لذيذ)
[ضحك الجمهور]
الإنترنت بطيء للغاية
لا نستطيع العمل
أحجام الملفات عملاقة
20 جيجا، 30 جيجا
لنرفعها علي الأنترنت ثم نحملها من جديد
سوف تأخذ الكثير من الوقت
توقفنا قليلا ثم بدأنا في التفكير مجددا
ما هو الحل
حملنا برنامج أسمه تيم فيور والذي يسمح لك
بالدخول من جهازك لجهازي
للعمل عليه لتوفير الوقت
وفرنا الوقت المهدور في تبادل الملفات
الملف الذي كان يستغرق رفعه ثم تحميله
بعد العمل عليه شهر
أصبح ينتهى منه في ثلاثة أيام فقط
وفرنا الكثير من الوقت
وغيرها من المشاكل
وهذا يثبت أنه دائما كان لدينا حلولا
مهما تعقدت المشكلة أو كبر حجمها
حتي لو جائت فجأة أو كان الوقت ضيق
لم نكن نيأس أبدا سواء حلت المشكلة
في يوم، أو أسبوع أو شهرا
لم نكن نيأس أبدا
لقد بدأنا في هذا المشروع منذ 2014
اليوم نحن في 2018
لأكون صريحا معكم كانت هناك مواقف كثيرة
تمنحنا قوة وتشجعنا علي تكملة الفيلم
سأعطيكم مثالا
قد تكون المواقف بكلمة واحدة أو شخص فعل
شيئا أثناء العمل نتج عنه حماسا للباقين
كان بعض الأفراد يبيعون بعض أغراضهم لشراء
ميكروفون للتسجيل
كان يعمل بعض الأفراد ساعات أضافية ليجنوا
المزيد من المال ليسجلوا أدوارهم في أستوديو
فقط لمدة ساعة
كان بعض الأفراد يسهرون عدة أيام لينهوا
أجزاء من الفيلم الخاص بنا
مثل دينو جانيك من مونتيجرو، وبالمناسبة هو
من القسم الموسيقي في الفريق
وهو من عزف الموسيقي التي سمعتوها منذ قليل
كما كانت هناك مواقف مضحكة فعنصر الكوميديا
لابد من وجوده
مثل فرانز روجامر هو ألماني وكان يسجل
مشهدا بمنزله علي الإنترنت كما تعلمون
وكان مشهد قتال مع تنين فأندمج قليلا
فظن جيرانه أنه يتشاجر مع لص
فاتصلوا بالشرطة
[ضحك الجمهور]
نحمد الله، مازال موجودا معنا
وغيرها من المواقف
كل موقف منها وكل فرد كان يتحمل الصعاب
من أجل الفيلم كان يزيد من حماس الباقين
وفي اللحظة التي تتكاسل فيها كنت تتذكر
مجهود الباقي فتعود للعمل
النتائج
بعد كل هذا الحديث أتظنون نتائج فيلم كهذا
هل ستكون مبهرة كهوليوود، متوسطة أم ضعيفة؟
قبل ان تجاوبوا دعونا نري النتائج بأنفسنا
هذه شخصية ثلاثية الأبعاد من الفيلم
كل الصور التي سيتم عرضها اليوم هي صور
حصرية للمؤتمر
ومن صنعنا بنسبة 100%
سواء الشخصيات، ألوانها، الإضاءة،
البيئة المحيطة، الحركة التي يتحركونها
العظام الوهمية المستخدمة لتحريكهم،
ملابس الشخصية
وسنناقش هذا لاحقا
البيئة العملاقة أو المدينة التي
ستدور فيها الأحداث
لقد درسنا جغرافيا ودرسنا تكوين الجبال
الأسوار، البيوت، الأنهار،
ثم قمنا بعمل كوكب
إذا ظننتم إن هذا شيئا مبهرا
فعليكم الانتظار للنهاية
هذا يثبت أنه لا يوجد ما هو مستحيل
بالفعل لا يوجد شيئا مستحيلا
لأنه من كان يتخيل أنه في 2014
كان هذا المشروع حلما لطالب ثانوية عامة
بمصر يحتسي الشاي ويشاهد التلفاز
يريد عمل فيلم بدون رأس مال
أو استديو، أو فريق عمل
من كان يتصور انه بعد سنوات، حاليا 4 سنوات
يصبح المشروع في هذه الهيئة
فلا يوجد ما هو مستحيل
كل ما أستطيع قوله أننا قد ربحنا
وسنظل نربح
دعوني أشارك معكم سر الخلطة
دعونا نتجول داخل الاستديو
الوهمي الخاص بنا
لنري كيف كنا نخرج هذه الشخصيات لتري النور
كما أخبرتكم من قبل أن الفيلم
مقتبس من رواية
في الرواية يوجد شرح تفصيلي لكل شخصية سواء
من الناحية الشخصية أو الخارجية كشكل
ولكني كمصمم أحتاج رؤية الشيء بعيني
لأصمم ما طلب مني كما هي
في خيالك أيها المخرج
يجب أن أري الفكرة بعيني
فبدأت في البحث عن فريق من الرسامين
لرسم رسومات تخيلية وبدأنا في رسم
أشكال تخيلية لشكل البطل
ثم فكرنا أن التصميم جميل ولكننا
لا نري وجهه
فبدأنا في رسم أشكال تخيلية أكثر وضوحا
هذه الرسومات مرسومة علي برنامج الفوتوشوب
ثم أخدنا خطوة أكبر وهي التفكير
في ملامح وجهه بدقة
وبدأنا في التطوير في هذه المرحلة ونقتبس
أشكال لممثين من هوليوود
ثم أنتقلنا من الرسم علي فوتوشوب الي
برامج التصميم ثلاثي الأبعاد
كبرامج مايا وثري دي ماكس وزي براش
وبدأنا في نحت الشخصية حتي
أًصبحت بهذا المنظر
ولكنا طمعنا أكثر وشعرنا أننا يمكننا
صنع المزيد في هذه الشخصية
فبدأنا دراسة المعادن
ما علاقة المعادن بالموضوع
الدرع الخاص بالبطل مصنوع من الذهب ولكن
علينا تحديد نوعية المعدن المصنوع منه الدرع
لتحديد نسبة انعكاس الضوء
وهل سوف يظهر قويا ام لا
ولكن هناك قطعة قماش بأسفل الدرع
فبدأنا دراسة التفصيل
بدأنا في استخدام برنامج مارفيلوس ديزاينر
لنتعلم كيفية تفصيل الملابس لصنع الفساتين
الخاصة بالشخصيات النسائية بالفيلم
وقطعنا الكثير من الأقمشة
بعد كل هذا كانت هذه هي النتيجة
هذه هي أخر صورة خرجت من المطبخ الخاص بنا
لشخصية البطل
بالتأكيد مازال ينقصها بعض التفاصيل ولكننا
وصلنا لدرجة عالية من الواقعية
خاصة بعد النظر للطريقة
التي بدأ بها المشروع
دعوني اسالكم سؤالا جميلا
شخصا يعمل في هذا المجال
ويفكر به منذ أعوام
ما هي الكلية الذي يدرس بها؟
أي تخمينات؟
تجارة
زراعة
فنون تطبيقية
حسنا بما أن أحد منكم لم يعرف
الكلية التي أدرس بها
اسمحوا لي أن أعيد تعريفكم بنفسي ولكن
بأسلوب مختلف هذه المرة
مرحبًا جميعا كيف حالكم اليوم
[ضحك الجمهور]
اسمي كيرلس رزق
أنا في السنة الثالثة بالجامعة
طالب في كلية لوجستكس
بالأكاديمية البحرية
تقديري امتياز للعام الثالث
ترتيبي التاسع علي دفعتي
ومنذ 3 أشهر فقط أصبحت
العاشر على مستوى العالم في سلاسل الأمداد
[تصفيق الجمهور]